all right here we are in miami super
bowl 54 coming up in just a few days and
one day before the super bowl the hall
of fame selection committee gets
together to determine the fate of 15
modern day finalists including reggie
former colts receiver reggie wayne's
first round pick in 2001 and a guy who
is on the doorstep of getting in how
nervous are you uh you know what i'm not
nervous yet it hasn't kicked in yet i
think as we get closer and closer to the
day maybe
it's you know i started getting some
jitters here and there but right now i'm
just enjoying the wave and
enjoying being paraded around what's the
best advice you've gotten on how to
handle your emotions on saturday while
you're waiting for
the knock the potential knock from the
big the biggest human on the biggest man
the biggest head the biggest body the
biggest suits in the world he's a big
guy he is a big guy
but i'm looking forward to seeing that
big guy you know but the
the one thing that i you know advice
that i was told they said hey
unplug your room
phone i said because if you get the
phone call that means you didn't get in
uh right they unplugged that phone right
that's what i was told hopefully
hopefully i wouldn't need that yeah you
won't i mean what's your current like
thought on the whole hall of fame
process with the wide receiver position
especially it's so it's log jamming it's
vlogging there's a lot of guys waiting i
mean you know that's up with me now it's
it's isaac bruce's torah holt i mean
like
these are guys that i was playing with
at the same time that
to me was different difference makers in
the like in the game so um
it's one of those positions where
i think it's going to be hard to
i know you guys are all hall of famers
yeah you know it's it's it's tough it
really is and that's what for me that's
what makes this so exciting because i
didn't expect to get this far on my
first ballot yeah and to be this far and
knowing all the guys that
paid played the game before me and was
in this situation that didn't make it
this far i mean man i'm just blessed i'm
i'm grateful well the thing that i think
bothers me all right just in this whole
thing especially for a guy like you or
isaac bruce yep
and i don't know how much you agree with
this but he didn't play in an era where
receivers got the cheap yards all the
time yeah you know it kind of came
towards the end of your career where
offenses started throwing bubble screens
for 150 yards a game you kind of had to
deal with the old rules a little bit
some of that uh and the offenses weren't
getting the cheap passing yards quite
the same and i think with those old
rules i i think it made guys
a little bit more hungrier
it makes made guys want it just a little
bit more right you know um
those those rules
made me ready for whatever was coming
you know and and i say that my last
three years i can see the change yeah i
saw the new wave coming in and you
mentioned the bubble screens and you you
look like yeah yeah all that stuff there
you go that's not even that you don't
have to be talented to get open that's
what i knew it was time for me to go
because it didn't excite me right it
really didn't it was almost it was
almost like i was you know playing with
my kids yeah you know i mean but
it's just it's just the times it's the
waves it's an adjustment and um
man i'm glad i'm glad i played when i
played hey reggie give me two names
one
the guy that you hated seeing across
from you and two the guy you loved
seeing across from you wow
hate it
yeah that's the easier one to go with
first because you you're gonna you're
gonna i'm gonna tell you this a lot of
people don't know what you guys would
know um
old school aaron glenn oh all right
number 31 number third one on the jets
but he also played with the houston
texans right right
he made me
as a young pup in the league he made me
take my film study to a whole nother
level how because every route i ran he
ran it before i did
so i'm like i gotta be doing something
wrong like how does he know i'm gonna
run this comeback and i hadn't even ran
10 yards down the field yet
so he made me critique myself a little
differently it made me study just a
little bit harder study yourself started
myself so you're not showing so i'm not
tender exactly so he he that was the one
guy because i was like
he was as we would say he was an og in
the game he knew every trick of the
trade you know what i mean so that was
one guy i hated going up against
the person i enjoyed going up against
was the whole jacksonville jaguars team
oh man i love playing against
jacksonville i mean jacksonville alone
i'm probably
2 000 something yards yeah you torched
them oh yeah i love i love them
that was a lot of guys when they get the
the the schedule they highlight that bye
week right i highlighted it with
jacksonville jaguars week that was the
one week i knew i was going to have fun
you um
you you guys were like special on
offense yeah a lot like kansas city
exactly you know it was you know they
got sammy and tyreek and mahomes and it
was manning and reggie and mark and
marvin right
um
well give me a psycho peyton manning
story like a psycho one to where you
know like we always hear about his
preparation things like that but was he
the type of guy to like call you at 11
30 at night and like tell you the new
signal for running a slant route
you know no he he wouldn't do that now
we had a ton of signals do you know you
i know that just made me have a bad
dream
i'll tell you what one time he invited
everybody to his house right we went
over there and it was it was just to go
hang out and eat and play pool and all
that thing
and he had a theater room
right so don't tell me he came you got
he went and watched film
we didn't watch film
we went in the theater room and the in
his theater room was exactly like
the meeting room at the complex what i
was like wait a minute am i back
at the coach facility
right it was everything from projector
to whiteboard to seats everything was
like i was back at the practice field
and i was like
bro you need to get out more yeah you
really need to get out more but that
just shows you how dedicated and how
how he wanted everything to feel like
he was
you know at the facility getting better
preparing himself i mean it's it's you
talked about the way prepared it was
it's no one in this world that i believe
prepares harder than peyton i really
believe like every day it's planned out
like if he's getting up at seven in the
morning at 705 he's gonna put his shoes
on at 17 he's gonna brush his teeth like
he is the one he's the ultimate pro when
it comes to being ready and nothing is
going to catch him off guard yeah and it
wasn't a surprise in 2012 with all the
changes the team was going through that
he would welcome something new because i
think he was rattled by coach is gone
gm's gone everything's different
everyone's gone you chose to stay and i
remember how stunned people were that
you chose to stay
talk us through what that transition was
like when you're the common thread back
to the super bowl teams and everything's
new and everything's different well for
one you know
back when i was playing when i first got
in the league you know guys
they took pride into trying to stay at
one place yeah not floating around right
and that that meant a lot to me that i
felt like that would be big for my
legacy to just to stick around
indianapolis
uh continue to build on what i had not
you know i didn't know
where it was gonna take me you know and
as they say you know the grass isn't
always green on the other side so i just
i just decided to stay and kind of work
on that mold of being an indianapolis
coat
and now it's my time to be a leader and
um
we bring in andrew luck you know we're
bringing it kobe fleeter we're bringing
it t.y hilton we're bringing in dwayne
allen i was out there with all rookies
yeah right and
i was like you know what
all my career i felt like i was
you know even in college and sometimes
in high school like i felt like
i was
you know the guy that didn't get his due
you know i would agree you got you got i
feel like santana
you're thunder yeah so it was always
something yeah i get to you know i get
to the nfl and marvin harrison was
already you're too nice that's what it
is and you know and that's what that's
what everybody says
but it's just me it it it really is so i
told myself yes hey
you know a lot of times people will say
hey reggie is only good because his
quarterback i'm like okay yeah negative
that's not real so now this is gonna be
a time for me to prove
is it's not just my partner exactly you
know so i'm there with all all rookies
and um
andrew luck comes in and you know i tell
angel soon as you walk in and you know
you can see him sweating sweating palms
wet you know i'm saying
just be yourself you don't have to be
peyton manning and be nobody just be
andrew luck and once he was able to just
finally take that that fresh breath
there
man we were we're a pretty good team
even a young team yeah let me take you
back even farther because we work with
we work with coach dungey all the time
okay what was your first impression of
coach dungey coming off of jim mora i
can't imagine any two more different
personalities than jim mora to tony
dungy but your first impression when
dungey showed up oh man you know not
throwing any shade on coach moore but
you know i was like
it's a breath of fresh air around here
you know um cause jim moore he was more
of
i know i want to say he had a military
background uh everything was
was more tensed you know um you know
it's and that's this going back to the
real tour days yeah i mean we were full
passed every single day two days and i
mean
we were we were beat up my rookie
everyone six and ten i think we went six
and ten just because we were tired you
know and then tony dungy comes in as a
guy who played in the game who
understood he was more of a player's
coach
he was almost like a father figure to a
lot of us
and
he let us
just be men
he trusted us
gave us respect
wanted us to be professionals didn't put
any pressure on us and um
as a player
you love that you love the coach that's
going to go to bat for you you love the
coach that you can knock on the door and
he opens the door and he listens to you
you know a lot of times you went to
coach dunn and say hey man a lot of guys
are
they're kind of feeling it a little bit
right and he was he said okay i'm glad
you all told me we're gonna back off a
little bit okay you know so like he was
the ultimate players coach but he was
also that coach that you didn't want to
let down you know and uh
man it's it's it's no one like him yeah
it really is yeah he's special he really
is he's a special human he's a really
nice guy like you are great just like
you are rich don't let that change you
wait man for the hall of fame purposes
it's just who i am i know it really is
you should hear chris around coach dungy
though chris has to constantly apologize
for his life i have a bad mouth you know
what i say lots of f words around him
and then i have to i have to follow by
going sorry it's hard coaching and i can
guarantee you you know
as you're dropping the f-bombs he's
rolling his eyes yes
but you know what he's uh
he gets it he really does it was one
time when you know coach coach dungeon
was cursed in practice what one time he
almost let it go
we were messing around and i guess we
wasn't locked in the way we should and
this this is uh my second year and kadri
ishmael was it was
messing around and he dropped the ball
and he should have caught it and
coach dungeon had i guess his cup had
been running over you know he had enough
and
he almost dropped the word and it got
everybody's attention everybody
oh
but he caught himself he caught himself
and
that's when we like hey
coach dungeon's mad we better tighten up
what was the the the f word maybe or the
s word i mean i don't know i would not i
would not say i know i will not run to
you
reggie's joining us today on behalf of
the nfl extra points credit card uh give
us a little bit about what you got going
on with amaranth yeah this extra points
credit card it's a credit card available
for all teams and what this credit card
does it's
it's it's available for the ultimate fan
if you really a true fan of football
this is a car that you want to have now
with every dollar you spend with this
card you gain points and with those
points you get things like
game tickets you get the vip experience
you can even get super bowl tickets
so like this is a card for the true fan
just think of you a fan and you're
sitting down and you fan of kansas city
chiefs right you're on the sideline and
you're looking at patrick mahomes warm
up he may even come and shake your hand
right that's things that this car can
give you and it's
something that money cannot buy
it really isn't so
if you're the ultimate fan this is a
card for you and learn more about this
just go to
nflextrapoints.com and you can learn
more
i i kind of like that i mean instead of
like i don't would never use the rewards
from like the normal credit card like
but i would use football i mean if you
if you like football and i'm spoiled and
i've been around this is what you can
get you can use this card it can get you
it can get you behind behind the curtain
all right thanks that people can't say
that i'm down for that sign me up on the
way out of the door take us behind
reggie wayne's curtain for the super
bowl who do you like in the game and
who's the mvp oh well you know it's the
quarterback's world you know it is
quarterback's world so i gotta i gotta
go uh i'm going kansas city patrick
mahomes mvp okay reggie great talking to
you good luck on saturday and uh we hope
to see you in a gold jacket appreciate
it guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports